the title of this panel is understanding
and overcoming gaps in measurement
modeling and regulation to implement
meaningful climate policy and the
purpose of the panel is several fold
first it's to highlight the need for and
the role of air quality measurements and
modeling and informing climate policy
the panel is also about considering
existing and potential air quality
regulations that can be used to
implement climate policies in the US and
particularly at the federal level using
the Clean Air Act and then finally the
panel is designed to consider how the
public perceives both climate science
and policy and ways in which the public
can be mobilized to support continued
efforts and regulations so we have three
excellent panelists today the first one
is Trudy strel demo who's an assistant
professor in geology and geophysics here
at Yale our second panelist will be dan
lash off who's the director of the
climate and clean air program at the
Natural Resources Defense Council and
then our final panelist will be cliff
Davidson who's the Thomas C and Colleen
L Wilmot professor of engineering at
Syracuse University so we're going to
have each of them give a presentation of
about 15 minutes I'm out and I'll
introduce the more formally as they come
up and then at the end we're going to
have a sort of a question and answer
session where small group here so I
think you can be very conversational so
our first speaker is going to be
professors 12mo who I mentioned is an
assistant professor in geology and
geophysics here at Yale she is an
atmospheric scientist and joined the
Yale faculty in 2010 after completing
postdoctoral research at both ETH Zurich
and the University of Oslo her research
uses climate models often combined with
remote sensing and institue and
laboratory experiments to better
understand how aerosol particles
influence regional and global climate in
particular via their effects on clouds
professor strove mo received her
bachelor of science and physics from the
University of Oslo her master of science
and meteorology from the University of
Washington in Seattle and then her PhD
in atmospheric science also from the
University of Oslo so professor scalfa
hope you want to come up and give your
presentation
thank you for us thank you all for
coming out in the snow like Bruce said I
think we're a small enough group that we
can make this fairly interactive and and
I only have a few slides and I I food
think if you have passions along the way
you may interrupt and go ahead and ask
so I wanted to talk about aerosols and
climate which is really what my group
works on here at Yale and I wanted to
address three issues or address three
questions one how what are the
contributions of arrow cells and
greenhouse gases in climate change how
well do we understand those
contributions and i also want to talk
about the role of black carbon in
particular black carbon has received a
lot of attention recently asks a
potential to both improve air quality
and cooler climate so that's an
interesting topic topic in this context
and then and with talking about what the
climate effect of cleaning the air could
be so the picture here is a nice example
of how aerosol pollution clearly has an
effect on both air quality in urban
areas particularly and also it's clear
that such a brown haze player will have
an effect on the energy balance of the
surface and that it will affect the
matter of sunlight that reaches the
surface so I'm going to talk about start
by talking about the climate effect of
aerosols in relation to greenhouse gases
in this figure some of you have probably
seen many many times before and I think
some other speakers yesterday showed it
as well so it's the forcing chart from
the last IPCC report which essentially
shows what the key drivers of climate
change have been since pre-industrial
times so any bar here where the warm
color represents a warming so you can
recognize all the well-known greenhouse
gases
at the top there have a warming effect
and then further down you can recognize
the aerosol draw aerosol effects on
climate so how the aerosols tend to
compensate for some of the warming
effect that the greenhouse gases help
what you also see from this this chart
is that there's a fairly large
uncertainty associated with the eris old
driver or the aerosol forcing of climate
change and unfortunately despite the
fact that we have you know a growing
community of people of scientists
working on this problem of what aerosols
how aerosols affect our climate those
error bars haven't really are those in
certain bars haven't really been reduced
over the last couple of decades and and
so that's a problem for several
different reasons at the bottom there is
the not the net driving force of climate
change and you can see that the
uncertainty bar from the aerosol
forcings propagates into the net forcing
and meaning we don't have a very good
understanding of the net what the net
driving force of climate change has been
in the past and also as we think about
improving air quality and reducing air
assault concentrations in the atmosphere
it also means that we don't have a very
good understanding of what that would do
to our climate and so why do we have
these huge uncertainty bars or error
bars associated with the aerosol effect
on climate well I most of my work as
Bruce said deals with modeling aerosol
effects on climate and it's a tremendous
challenge to represent these processes
in climate models that have our solution
of you know on the order of hundred
kilometers so what this slide shows it's
just the range of different sources that
emit aerosols to our atmosphere so again
you recognize the picture of urban
pollution and the effort upper left-hand
side we also have natural aerosols that
are emitted from deserts from sea spray
and so on
with the anthropogenic aerosol particles
and we have a range of different
anthropogenic aerosol sources that all
emit aerosols with somewhat different
composition and then what that fixture
in the middle shows is how how air is
different eras of species also mix in
the atmosphere and that affects their
properties in complex space and also how
they influence climate so that makes
this this problem of representing
aerosols in climate models a very
challenging one now in the previous
chart that I showed you from IPCC you
saw that all the aerosol different
aerosol species were lumped together in
one forcing bar and we saw that that was
a cooling effect that all all aerosol
particles combined have on our climate
but we you probably most of you know
well that different types of aerosols
affect our climate differently so on the
upper left-hand side here now is the
middle illustration or a schematic of
how some aerosols are very efficient
scatterers of solar radiation and
reflect more sunlight back to space and
they have the traditional cooling effect
that we know but then other aerosols
fusion species and especially black
carbon absorbs sunlight and and I've
Illustrated that on the right hand side
here from a modeling study where you see
the anything in blue here represents a
cooling a negative forcing and anything
in red represents a positive forcing in
hands of warming so you have the warming
effect of black carbon on the upper
right-hand side and the cooling effect
of sulfate on the lower right-hand side
and as we think about cleaning the air
and what that will do to our climate you
have to think about these competing
effects and also the problem that these
different species are often committed
from a lot of sectors and also there's
this additional effect that aerosols can
have by affecting clouds so if
they're a somewhat soluble in water they
have the ability to form cloud droplets
on them and that has the effect of
brightening clouds and that's also a
cooling and sulfate particles are
efficient that doing that black carbon
particles not so much unless they're
mixed an age in the atmosphere in case
the story becomes a little more
complicated yeah
sweet side of a page rooms of the levels
or the concentrations so that
policymakers could know how to keep
these two yeah you know sulfate and by
carbon is often committed and that's why
you you often see the maximum warming
and maximum cooling coinciding but in
terms of you know optimization of we
know what what the optimal emission of
black carbon 22 sulfate would be for
both air quality and climate I don't
think anyone has done that study but
certainly a us perhaps as I move on to
my next slide here of you know this
study just came out and I'm the 19th
author I think on this on this paper it
was a major collaboration and I made
quite a splash to study when he came out
got a lot of attention in the media and
so what I'm showing here is now a
similar forcing chart to what we had
from the IPCC but now we're only looking
at the different black carbon effects on
climate and so what was so interesting
about this study or what the media
thought was interesting about this study
was that we came up with a much stronger
warming effect from black carbon then
what for example IPCC had come up with
and part of that was factoring in that
we have probably in our climate modeling
studies and chemical transport modeling
we've been under estimating sources or
emissions in certain parts of the world
so we came up with a warming that is now
only only second to co2 so so this study
makes black carbon the second most
important driver of climate change or
global warming after co2 so so that was
very interesting but again there are
some some caveats you know people get
excited because if you this means that
there would be a tremendous climate
benefit from reducing black carbon in
addition to the air quality
benefit that you would have from it but
of course there are a number of caveats
and you can see that the second group of
forcings there represents how these
black carbon particles interact with
clouds and there's you know very large
and certainly or error bars associated
with each of these contributions so
unfortunately then at the bottom here
where you have the total climate forcing
from black carbon only you have this
very strong warming of 1.1 watts per
square meters so that's that's almost as
strong a warming as co2 has but there's
also this very wide uncertainty bar
unfortunately that propagates from each
of the different mechanisms through
black car through which black carbon can
influence climate but it adds up to a
very wide uncertainty arranged in in our
best estimate and then the bottom bar
there you can see is slightly negative
and that's black carbon and all its
committed species and that's factoring
in black carbon rich sources only so
there again you get this competing
effect of the warming black carbon and
the cooling sulfate and if you simply
went for reducing black carbon rich
sources only you would actually risk to
contribute somewhat to to global warming
you would of course have also the
benefit of cleaning the air but in terms
of the climate there's there's no
benefit you know according to according
to that lower bar but again very wide in
certain new ranges yes everything that
is committed sulphate organic carbon
anything that is committed from carbon
rich sources so that's essentially lima
is burning and diesel fuel burning
from black carbon exactly exactly you
can there are certain sectors that you
could target that are where the majority
of the missions are black carbon so
those would be that the obvious ones to
target and try to reduce but but you
always have to be aware of the co
emitted species and what they do so so a
bit of a challenge there and both in
terms of understanding some of the of
the mechanisms through which black
carbon influenced our climate and also
the competing effect of black carbon and
it's it's committed species so finally
just looking at reducing air salt
concentrations in general in the
atmosphere because in the long run we
mean for air quality purposes we may not
only want to reduce by carbon we may
want to reduce aerosols in general for
for health benefits and so what I'm
showing here is actually a recent work
from my group where we've tried to
decompose the temperature trend of the
last well the last 40 years of the last
century and so the red curve here
represents the warming that we would
have had if we didn't have this masking
effect is compensating effect from
aerosols which in in the total is a
cooling that that compensates for some
of the greenhouse warming and and that
in that effect of the Arizona that
cooling effect of the Arizona loan is in
the in the green bar there and then the
the blue or the purple line
represents what the warming that we've
actually seen this was a statistical
analysis using observations so there's
no climate modeling involved here for
those of you are skeptical skeptical
about climate modeling results perhaps
rightly so so a point that I wanted to
make with this figure is also that we
have we have already been cleaning our
air not and not targeting selected
selectively black carbon and some of
accelerated warming that we saw on the
you know the end of the last century was
probably partly caused by us cleaning
the air and so this this is important to
keep in mind as we think about air
quality and and the fact that as we
reduce that not only black carbon but
also other aerosol specious it may
contribute your accelerating global
warming so we need to think carefully
about what sectors we want to target if
we don't want to have this acceleration
of global warming as an unintended
consequence of cleaning our air
not allowed
relatively constant
yeah yeah that's an excellent question
and I think depending on you know
different regions of the world you'll
have different trajectories in terms of
aerosol concentrations and also what we
used here was actually we had surface
stations of the amount of radiation
solar radiation that we should the
ground and that was went into this
statistical analysis and so there there
was this stabilization if you know if
you looked at all the stations that we
had there was the stabilization
stabilization at the end of last century
but certainly in China there wouldn't
have been stabilization there would have
been a steady reduction in the amount of
sunlight I reaches the surface because
of increased air pollution so
unfortunately we don't have a whole lot
of stations in China there most of them
are in Japan so so our Asian stations
are in Japan which isn't necessarily
representative of what's going on in
China or India I think I've gone way
over time already it's all right i think
that i'll skip the this slide and just
move on to my my food for thought here
so i started out with saying that the
the aerosol forcing in total if you just
lump all aerosols together it's
compounded comparable and magnitude to
the total greenhouse forcing but of
opposite sign so it has been masking a
lot of the warming we would otherwise
have seen from greenhouse gases but as
we know very well different eras all
species affect climate differently and
if we could isolate black carbon and
reduce black carbon emissions in
particular that would that would have a
very beneficial effect to our climate as
well as air quality unfortunately there
are aspects of black carbon effects on
climate that we don't understand very
well and there's also the caveat of
committed species that may not give us
the the wanted climate effect if we
reduced carbon black carbon rich
emission sources so
there is the risk as we attempt to
improve air quality that we are going to
accelerate global warming so we have to
think carefully about which sectors to
target and also we should work hard to
reduce the error bars associated with
the black carbon forcing and yeah our
studies are we study show that as much
as perhaps half of the warming from
Venus gases has been matched by aerosol
so far so if we were to remove that
masking we could we could see very
dramatic climate change so that's
certainly food for thought I think
Thanks okay thank you very much thanks
to all of you are hanging in there in
the in the snowstorm yet last night mark
Jacobson presented a compelling picture
of how we could eliminate global warming
pollutants by transforming our energy
system to rely on when water and Sun and
then this morning Dan SD really gave a
very interesting talk about things that
Connecticut is doing at the state level
to move that agenda forward he said some
disparaging things about Washington and
but I want to give a sense that there
actually is an opportunity to do some
things in Washington that would actually
work with the states to move that agenda
forward so you know from a theoretical
perspective the problem is too much
carbon pollution other pollutants as
well we can talk about the interaction
but if you think about that well you
know academic solution is pretty simple
you put a tax on carbon that will raise
the cost of using fossil fuels and make
thick those wonderful technologies that
Marc Jacobs I'm talking about more
cost-effective will make that transition
everybody's happy in practice it turns
out to be rather difficult to get that
done politically we can talk a lot in
the panel about why that's the case but
I my view having spent 20 years in
Washington
is it's not going to happen any time
soon we worked very hard to try to get
legislation through in 2008-2009 our
2009-2010 and it didn't happen and so
the assumption has been Washington is
broken you can't do anything federally
it's all going to be up to the states
kinds of things that dana st is doing
and that's very important work yeah
there's the Clean Air Act but the
conventional wisdom is maybe you can get
a little bit of carbon reduction using
the Clean Air Act but it's going to be
very expensive and it's not going to
make much difference so we been looking
very carefully at that question and put
together a proposal and an analysis of
that proposal which shows that that
conventional wisdom is wrong that you
can actually get big reductions using
the Clean Air Act that are quite
cost-effective given the way that the
law is written and the opportunities
that we have to move to clean energy so
that's what I'm going to talk about I'm
going to start with the bottom line
we're focused here on setting carbon
pollution standards for existing power
plants for any lawyers in the room
there's at least one section 111 d of
the clean interact and of course power
plants are responsible for about forty
percent of us co2 emissions so it's by
far the biggest source with the
standards that the approach that I'm
going to describe we found that we could
get more than 500 million tons of co2
emission reductions by 2020 that's about
twice the reductions that will be
achieved from the clean car standards
which was by far the most significant
step that President Obama's
administration took in their first term
so they set standards that will actually
cut the carbon emissions per mile from
new vehicles in half by 2025 quite
significant the vehicle the
power plant standards i'm going to
describe could do twice as much as that
along with that you would also reduce
significantly other pollutants so-called
pollutants from coal plants particularly
a sulfur dioxide and have significant
immediate health benefits this is
accomplished by driving investments into
clean energy so in terms of what
Commissioner Esty was talking about the
economics as well as environmental and
energy component there's an investment
in a particular energy efficiency that
brings with it substantial job
opportunities and all this can be
accomplished at a relatively low cost on
the national basis net we find four
billion dollars compared with benefits
of 25 to 60 billion so up to fifteen to
one benefit to cost ratio and I'll
explain more about that as I go forward
um so the way this is being accomplished
is that EPA is required to issue an
emission guideline document which sets
out standards that would apply to
existing power plants and some
compliance provisions and then under
this section of the Act it's actually a
partnership between the federal
government and the state so states then
submit implementation plans about how
they would comply with those standards
what we proposed to do is take advantage
of that federalist structure to set
emission rate standards that are depend
on the starting generation mix in each
state so a state that is much more coal
dependent in its generation mix in a
baseline period think of North Dakota
which had one hundred percent
essentially a hundred percent of its
electricity generated by coal their
emission rate standard would be
different from Connecticut which is
mostly natural gas-fired to start with
their rates would have to get closer
together by 2020 but they wouldn't
converge to the same number so this
allows us to take into account these
different regional differences in energy
it makes the proposed
a little more fair and hopefully more
politically feasible once you establish
what the state standard is then it's
fuel and technology neutral within the
state so all fossil generators would
have to meet that same number that's
possible obviously coal and gas plants
have very different emission rates so
how could they meet the same number well
that's where the second key component of
our proposal comes in is a flexible
compliance regime that allow takes a
system-wide approach to the fossil
generation fleet and includes crediting
for energy efficiency and renewable
energy measures we did our analysis
assuming that compliance was done on a
state-by-state basis but we would also
recommend that that states be encouraged
and allowed to opt into a multi-state
program so they could actually trade or
average across state lines in order to
comply and then the other key piece of
the flexibility is that the federal
template is or the federal guideline
that EPA issues would be a template
against which you could measure
alternative state programs so Dan nasty
would be able to say well you know
Connecticut's in Reggie we're doing all
this energy efficiency we have this big
micro grid program we're going to you
know get every school of Connecticut as
Mike what I push them on to be solar by
2020 we our analysis shows that the
emissions in Connecticut would be lower
than what they would be if we just
applied the federal template and if he
can make that demonstration then EPA
would be able to approve that as a state
plan so they don't have to follow the
same structure that would be in in in
the guideline so it's a little bit more
about the flexibility conventionally we
think of the clean air act as requiring
a mission control equipment to be bolted
on to existing power plants or other
industrial sources and of course that
that can achieve some emission
reductions if you think about a typical
coal-fired power plant
with an admission rate of say twenty one
hundred pounds per megawatt-hour there
are things you can do to improve the
efficiency of the boiler add electronic
boiler controls and things of that
nature and those are estimated to
achieve about a five percent up to about
a five percent reduction in the carbon
emission rate from from that unit now
there's other things you could do you
could burn biomass along with coal or
natural gas along with coal in those
boilers you could retrofit with carbon
capture equipment to capture that co2
and store it in geological formation
technically feasible tends to be very
expensive we don't think EPA could
justify requiring all coal plants to
apply those types of measures at this
point in time so if you're stuck with
what you can do at individual units you
probably are limited to a few percent
reduction in emissions as something that
EPA could accomplish through its
regulation and that was sort of the
conventional wisdom well again we can't
do that much with Clean Air Act but you
don't have to stop there under our
proposal on additional measures would be
about count towards compliance in fact
the intent is everything that actually
reduces emissions from the power sector
should be able to be counted towards
compliance with the standards so in
addition to improvements at individual
units you can shift dispatch from high
emitting cold units to lower admitting
natural gas combined cycle units at
least at the at the power plant stack
that's about a fifty to sixty percent
reduction in the emission rate because
you're allowed to comply on average
across the whole fleet that would count
towards compliance in addition to that
we propose that incremental generation
from zero emitting sources a wind or
solar would be able to earn a credit
towards compliance now these sources
aren't regulated under the Clean Air Act
because they're non emitting but the
regulated sources would be able to
satisfy part of their requirement by
obtaining credits from Inc
generation from from these sources and
finally we propose to do the same thing
with energy efficiency so improvements
in energy efficiency that are verified
by state agency so Dan would basically
say here's the programs that we've
implemented to do energy efficiency
we've done this measurement and
verification here's how many megawatt
hours we've saved those would get a
credit towards compliance in the exact
same way that increases in renewable
energy would so if you do all that we
find that you can get really significant
emission reductions here's we modeled
this using a model of the electricity
system called the integrated planning
model it's the same model that EPA uses
for regulatory analysis many utilities
use it as well this is the reference
case the reference case assumes
implementation of the mercury and air
toxic standards so that's in both cases
so we're looking just at the effect
incrementally of the carbon pollution
standards pretty gradual growth much
slower growth than we saw in the 90s for
example that's because energy efficiency
is already built into the baseline to
some extent our growth and electricity
demand is not that high also we are
seeing you know some coal plants
retiring more reliance on natural gas
but nonetheless the baseline here shows
you know gradual increases in emissions
sort of back to their peak level of
which was in 2005 by by 2020 with the
carbon pollution standards in place we
would be on this trajectory which gets a
twenty-six percent reduction below 2005
levels by 2020 a thirty-four percent
reduction below 20 below 2005 by 2025 so
that that difference between those two
lines is the 560 million tons of carbon
reductions in 2020 that I talked about
at the beginning
oh and because of the flexible
compliance and particularly because of
energy efficiency as a very cost
effective way to reduce emissions that
can be accomplished at very low cost we
are able to use the model to estimate
the total change in the cost of
delivering electricity services in the
country about four billion dollars on an
annualized basis in 2020 and that
compares with benefits of 25 to 60
billion and those benefits have two
components the bottom component in blue
are the benefits from reducing it's
particularly so2 emissions those occur
basically because energy efficiency as
part of the compliance energy efficiency
is replacing a significant amount of the
coal-fired generation would otherwise
occur and so you get incremental
reductions in sulfur and NOx emissions
beyond what would be achieved by the
mercury air toxic standards and other
pollution standards which are already
assumed with the baseline it surprised
me how big that was because I'd kind of
assumed that those standards were pretty
tough and there weren't going to be that
many you know that much conventional
pollution that you would also get out
but it's significant there's EPA uses
epidemiological models to estimate the
avoided mortality associated with that
and you use a statistical sort of value
of life kind of measure and you get this
value of eleven to twenty six billion
dollars or something like that from the
immediate health benefits of those and
then the carbon benefits are evaluated
based on a social cost of carbon concept
the low estimate uses the
administration's number for that which
is twenty-five dollars per per ton of
co2 in 2020 the higher estimate uses a
value that's recalculated using a lower
discount rate that we think is more
appropriate for an intergenerational
problem like this came out to fifty-nine
dollars per ton
and that gives you the higher value of
together a total of sixty billion so
just finish by showing how this
positions the US as a whole so now we're
looking at total energy related co2
emissions flatline is 2005 levels that
the dashed line in 2020 is the seventeen
percent reduction target that was both
in the legislation that had passed the
house in 2009 and also has been endorsed
by President Obama and and then it
continues to towards the eighty percent
reduction by 2050 number so II I a the
annual the energy statistical arm of the
Department of Energy every year issues a
sort of official energy forecast this is
their their estimate from 2011 modest
growth but you know getting up above
2005 levels around 20 30 or so now few
years back those projections like if you
look to their projection from 2005 it
would be literally off the chart so you
know we've actually made a lot of
progress in the sense that the baseline
forecast has been coming down and down
but obviously not nowhere close to the
the kind of reduction trajectory we need
to be on so but each year it gets a
little better this was 2012 and that's
2013 so that one was just released in
December they kind of incorporate new
policy once it's finalized so they don't
project anything that's not actually a
final regulation so it's pretty
conservative and what's included in
calculating those lines but this 2013
forecast includes the car standards that
i mentioned for example and includes the
effect of the mercury and air toxic
standards but it doesn't include any of
the energy efficiency standards that
that the department of energy is sort of
planning to do but hasn't yet finalized
but in 2012 they did why they call it an
extended
policies case that assumes some of these
kind of additional policies that it can
be reasonably anticipated but aren't yet
file and that gives you that orange line
essentially flat emissions out to 2030
2035 so that's sort of the best kind of
business as usual if we don't have
federal standards what we're looking at
is roughly constant emissions of co2 if
we layer on top of that the power plant
carbon pollution standards that I just
described we get to this Green Line
which gets you eighty percent of the way
to the 2020 target you ought further in
time it gets more and more difficult but
what I conclude from this is that with
power plant standards and other measures
that the administration has the
authority to do under current law the
2020 target seventeen percent below 2005
levels is within reach and actually
earlier this week world resources
institute published an analysis that
reached the same conclusion their
analysis a little bit more detailed in
that they looked at not just co2 but the
full set of greenhouse gases it's a
little more challenging when you do that
because the baseline forecast for co2 as
i showed you basically constant by the
baseline forecast for hfcs and methane
is for significant growth so you have to
compensate for that but nonetheless they
concluded that with aggressive
implementation of existing authority we
can achieve this this target so all is
not lost in Washington I'm actually
quite optimistic that the Obama
administration is going to move in this
direction the president said far more
about climate change in his second
inaugural speech than anybody I know
expect is really more than I expected
more than any other policy issue and
we'll be listening very very carefully
on Tuesday when we've been told he will
say more about
climate change in the state of the union
address including hopefully providing
some specifics about what he plans to do
about it Thanks thank you dr. lash off
our third speaker is cliff Davidson who
as I mentioned is the Thomas and Colleen
Wilmot professor of engineering at
Syracuse University he's also an
atmospheric scientist and he holds
appointments in both the civil and
environmental engineering department and
the Syracuse center for center of
excellence and environmental and energy
systems he's also the founding director
for the Center for Sustainable
engineering which is a partnership
between Carnegie Mellon the University
of Texas at Austin Arizona State Georgia
Tech and Syracuse University he joined
Syracuse in 2010 but prior to that he
served for 33 years on the faculty of
Carnegie Mellon in both the department's
of civil and environmental engineering
and engineering and public policy
professor Davidson's research covers
many topics i'm going to highlight two
of them here his long-term research
interest is on environmental transport
and fate of atmospheric aerosols
especially trace metals and he's also
currently researching Urban
Redevelopment for sustainability
considering the role of green
infrastructure in helping to solve air
and water management problems he
received his Bachelor of Science in
electrical engineering from Carnegie
Mellon and a master of science as well
as his PhD in environmental engineering
science from Caltech thank you very very
much Bruce and and I want to begin by
thanking Nina and Peter for the
invitation to come and participate on
this this very exciting panel so we
heard this morning first from dan st of
course about what's being done in
connecticut some very exciting things
and and then transitioning into this
section Trudy I thought gave a really
nice background of the the science
associated with the the role of aerosols
to basically counterpose the effect of
greenhouse gases and then Dan talked
about the policy options that that we
have so what we're now going to do is
essentially look at a third category of
importance here that actually relates
both to policy and to science which
involves people's behavior and how we
can understand how people will behave
relative to different policies and
relative to what they understand about
the science particularly regarding what
technologies they will accept and also
what they know what they understand
about the different technologies so we
know that there are a lot of societal
obstacles to change we know in
particular that new technologies have to
have attributes other than Environmental
Protection people in general of course
we're excluding people in this room but
in general people will will not react to
knowledge that a behavior change will
have a good positive major positive
effect on the environment they're
generally has to be something in it fort
for me is the the standard public
attitude and I think that's important to
keep in mind the the rebound effect is
actually quite an important one and one
that has not been thought about a whole
lot but in fact let's say that you
insulate your house and you have been
keeping your your winter thermostat on
say a day like today at maybe 65 degrees
so you've been wearing a heavy sweater
around the house then you decide that
you're going to do the environmentally
correct thing and you're going to add
insulation all around the house
most people when they when they take a
step forward like that the next thing
that happens is their attitude changes a
little and they say you know I have
really done something good for the
environment I've done my part I can now
live a little more comfortably so what
do they do with their thermostat instead
of 65 maybe they'll move that up to 68
or 69 so in fact that is known as the
rebound effect and in some cases that
rebound can offset any gains that were
made by the addition of insulation so
this is really a made a major obstacle
the drop in the bucket effect obviously
it's very easy for people to think how
can i how can I make a difference
naturally dan I thought alluded to that
issue very nicely with people who say
how how can we possibly confront what's
going on in Washington right right now
that's kind of an example of the drop in
the bucket effect basically you've got
more powerful interests you've got an
enormous number of people of power and
influence how can we have an effect if
there are sacrifices to be made others
should make the sacrifice the NIMBY
phenomena not in my backyard and of
course all of us are familiar with that
have any of you heard of the banana
affect any of you know what the banana
effect is build absolutely nothing
anywhere near anything and that really
is an extension of the NIMBY effect and
then lastly and particularly important
is poor understanding of technologies
and in this most recent study our group
looked at what people understand and
what they don't understand about
technologies and how that can impact
their their behavior so in fact I'm
going to summarize a few of these let's
see there should be half a dozen of
these issues where we looked at what is
the single most effective thing you can
do to conserve energy asked in a survey
that that our group conducted and here
you could see the results turning off
lights was about twenty percent in
twenty percent of respondents that was
the single most effective thing well
unfortunately while turning off the
lights is a very nice gesture it doesn't
say very much energy compared to the
other things that we do so that's a real
problem conserve energy in general that
was fifteen percent basically people who
were not able to identify specific
things that that they could do use that
driving less using bicycles using public
trans transit about a thirteen percent
of our respondents changing setting on
our thermostats about six percent
changing lifestyle and do not have
children is another another six percent
unplugging appliances again a nice
gesture but what does it really do so
this is about two-thirds of our
respondents if you add up those numbers
about sixty six percent and then the
other third of the respondents basically
chose miscellaneous items maybe one or
two percent fruit for each of those so
in fact there isn't a major consensus on
what people feel they can do but
certainly they're not identifying the
most important things except perhaps the
idea of driving less using bicycles
using public transit that's something
that that can have an effect and it's
doable although we're going to look at
how doable it is in a few minutes now
one thing to notice here is that all of
these things that people suggested our
curtailment efforts they're not
efficiency improvement well when you
think about it that's really unfortunate
because efficiency improvement first of
all can have a bigger effect than
curtailment given what we know about
people's curtailment and secondly
unfortunately these issues in
curtailment are not like
to be actually followed through by
people and we'll be looking at that as
well so it's interesting but it's
unfortunate that people mentioned
curtailment and they think first of
curtailment rather than improving energy
efficiency which is foot which is far
more effective and we believe that
that's probably because of the lack of
understanding of efficiency improvement
so in this particular set of questions
what we did is we asked people to
identify how much energy is used by
different appliances and devices around
the home compact fluorescent bulbs
laptop computers stereo desktop computer
and so forth but we also ask them how
much energy could be saved by certain
switches changing for example from
higher wattage bulbs to lower wattage
incandescent bulbs replacing
incandescent with compact fluorescents
turning up the thermostat and summer
turning down the thermostat in winter
changing the setting on the washing
machine and lion drying clothes in the
summer rather than using a dryer the
shape of this curve is is very important
and very revealing because what we see
is that the estimates are not too far
off for low energy of devices but when
we get to high energy devices that could
really make a difference we find that
people in general greatly underestimate
the amount of energy that they think
they're using and particularly
interesting is to look at how quickly
this curve levels off even when you go
to major energy consumers such as a room
air conditioner versus essential air
conditioner so you've got the actual
energy used versus the perceived energy
and what you see is that the perceived
energy is virtually the same in other
words people think that essential air
conditioner in their home may use on the
order of
twenty percent more energy than a room
air conditioner when in fact the reality
is that it's more than a factor of three
which is the difference of course on the
on the x axis between these two so
essentially what this is telling us is
that human perception of energy use
cannot really encompass the enormous
changes in energy when you get up to
major appliances people have difficulty
in understanding that some appliances
can use an order of magnitude or more
energy compared to smaller appliances
there are limited maybe thirty percent
or fifty percent increases it's
difficult for them to appreciate more
than that you can see that there's a
substantial spread n actually equals 505
for this this particular curve so we had
a good statistical sample and this is
actually a random sample of 50 of our of
our participants but in fact what you
see is that basically the shape of the
curve is very similar for virtually all
of our participants in other words
pretty much everybody is encumbered by
this lack of understanding of the
enormous range of energies that you can
have so what can we say from that curve
well the perception curve is relatively
flat there's a slight over estimate for
low energy appliances but it's actually
pretty close but there's a large under
estimate for high-energy appliances and
that's really where it's important
overall we're talking about an under
estimate of close to a factor 3 so
people don't appreciate the amount of
energy that their activities and their
appliances are responsible for okay so
let's talk about a different survey in
this case um we we began by looking at
what experts have decided are the most
efficient actions that people can take
to reduce their energy and we surveyed
people about how easy or difficult
would it be to make those changes so if
we look at the various effective actions
that were identified in this study this
is Gardner and stern we're talking about
first some fairly low ones or placing
100-watt light bulbs with 2 75 watt
light bulbs replacing incandescent bulbs
decreasing the home thermostat in winter
increasing the air conditioner
thermostat and summer increase the
thermostat in your refrigerator and in
your freezer decrease in the washing
machine temperature following cartoon
ups at prescribed intervals reducing
highway speed the maximum highway speed
from 7260 reducing the use of your TV
set by twenty-five percent and replacing
poorly insulated windows with highly
insulated windows ok those are the first
10 but in fact there are five more and
if we look at those carpool to work
replacing a non energy star washer with
an energy star washer replacing a an
existing inefficient home furnace with a
high-efficiency furnace replacing a 20
mile per gallon car with a more
efficient car drying clothing on a
clothesline instead of using a dryer so
some of these were repeats for what we
also ask people to estimate the energy
use for but now we're asking a different
question which is how difficult would it
be for you to to make these changes so
what did we find ok so here is a summary
of the results and what we find is in
general a very poor understanding of how
easy or how difficult it will be for
people to change their behavior in other
words we're asking the question are
people realistic about how hard or how
easy it is for them to make changes so
we let me go back so we've got the
percentage of the total energy saved by
these different activity
on the y-axis versus how easy or hard it
will be and this is a seven point scale
that has been adopted by social be hit
and behavioral scientists basically
going from extremely easy very easy
somewhat easy over 2f this is the
neutral position neither easy nor hard
somewhat hard very hard and extremely
hard and these words were chosen based
on what behavioral scientists have found
will they certainly trigger the the
proper thoughts and people for their
perceptions about changing behavior so
what we see is first of all all of these
15 behaviors of Gardner and stern all of
them are to the left of neither easy nor
heart which means that across the board
all of these behaviors were viewed to be
easy there were viewed be easing now
some of them were viewed to be less easy
than others but all of them were viewed
to be easy and in particular let me
point out that the two that seemed to be
closest to that neutral line are
carpooling and purchasing a more
efficient car we know that purchasing a
more efficient car is a big step it
involves shelling out money it's always
a big step when people buy a car and to
make a decision based on the energy
efficiency is something that with
current gasoline prices we know that
gasoline prices have not been high
enough to greatly affect people's choice
and that's why in fact we still have a
fairly high percentage of cars on the
road that our SUVs and high gasoline
usage vehicles we also know that
carpooling is not very popular we know
it's very difficult
for people to make the decision to team
up with another family and of course we
heard from dan st this morning about
what segments of the population we're
talking about here so mothers who have
to pick up their kids drive their kids
to soccer games and so forth it's going
to be very difficult for them to time
those activities with others so we know
carpooling this tough but in any case
the the net result here is that people
do not have a good understanding of how
difficult it is for them to change their
own behavior that's this is what we what
we learned from the survey okay even if
we were to educate people as to the
actual energy consumption of their
choices and even if they wanted to
reduce consumption it still wouldn't be
easy to change behavior change in fact
is extremely difficult and for my last
couple of slides I'm going to now talk a
little bit about some studies of
changing people's behavior this has been
most studied for addictive behavior but
in fact behavioral scientists have come
up with some very interesting results
that have shown that the same reasons
for people having difficulty in changing
chemically addictive behaviors are also
reflected in the difficulty that people
have in changing long-standing habits
which is very revealing because all of
us can appreciate how difficult it is
for a drug addict say to be removed from
drugs and an alcoholic to be removed
from from alcohol so this is this is a
very revealing finding actually and I'll
refer to the work of Prochaska which is
actually this is very interesting
because recently I learned from a
physician's organization that the pro
chaska paper is now required reading for
medical doctors and met
school as we're going through school so
this is something that is is obviously
realized as being extremely important
and this has become a classic paper even
though it's it's not tremendously old
there's the pre contemplation stage
people are unaware of their problems no
intent to change then there's
contemplation which is at least people
become aware of their problem but
they're not ready yet then there's
preparation this is when people say okay
I'm going to do something about my
problem within the next month then
there's action and then there's
maintenance which is constant and that
is work to prevent a relapse and the way
that prochaska modeled this is actually
as a spiral diagram where you start off
with pre contemplation you work your way
up to contemplation preparation then you
take action but in fact the problem is
that unless you have been successful for
at least six months in this loop you are
likely to relapse when you relapse you
don't fall all the way back to pre
contemplation you may only fall back to
preparation you may fall back to
contemplation but you're going to be
able to work your way back up a little
bit easier but in fact the goal is to
get up to the maintenance stage and a
lot of people have difficulty with the
idea that this maintenance is something
that's going to take an effort for the
rest of their life so knowing that these
stages can also be applied to people's
long-standing behaviors including things
like driving their car to work is
something that can inform us on how
difficult it might be for four people
even the most well-intentioned people to
change their their behavior so
conclusions from from just these this
small subset of studies are first of all
people's thoughts about energy
conservation or mainly curtailment
rather than improving efficiency when in
fact improving efficiency
can actually buy us more energy savings
and it's going to be a combination of
improvement in efficiency and
curtailment public understanding of
energy use day-to-day act of day-to-day
activities is really poor and we've seen
that we've also looked at the i'm not
sure if any of you are familiar with the
neb scale the national like illogical
paradigm scale but one can use that
scale that's been tested with tens of
thousands of people to determine an
individual's environmental attitudes and
so we tested all of our subjects with
the neb scale and so we know what what
correlations exist and what correlations
don't exist in terms of environmental
attitudes and then thirdly people
believe that change is easier than it
really is and that leads to overly
optimistic predictions and it really
gives us an idea of the challenges that
that we face and and that we need to be
aware of so with that I will pit stop
okay so I think we just had three really
good presentations covering kind of full
range of issues starting first with some
of the issues and the sort of climate
science and Atmospheric measurement
modeling moving on to some policy and
then issues of behavioral science I
think we have maybe about half an hour
and what I want to do is just sort of
open it up to your questions if you want
to ask any of the individual speakers or
if you have broader questions of the
panel and we do have a microphone so if
you could wait just until you get it but
does anyone have a question because i'll
start off i had a question for dan it to
me you know the curve that you presented
in terms of the potential emissions
reductions from the i don't want to call
it a cap-and-trade but that's how i'm
thinking about it potential program is
very striking and and we're also hearing
that you know there's some momentum in
Washington perhaps perhaps there's some
signaling going on from the White House
about you know being more open or or
pushing something forward I'm just
wondering if you could say
a few words about how you see how you
see that unfolding if what we're seeing
is proper signaling then then how does
this turn into the full implementation
of the plan over how many years and what
does it look like in general yeah so
it's I'm optimistic but that doesn't
mean it's going to be easy the sort of
regulatory schedule that we have kind of
sketched out and I think is possible is
starting Tuesday the president gives
some kind of clear signal that he once
EPA to move forward that's that's
important because this is challenging
and without White House support even
though EPA has a legal obligation
actually do this that doesn't mean they
would do it so it's going to be critical
to have that that White House support
EPA has indicated that they what they
would actually do before they proposed a
program a standard for existing power
plants they want to have a process of
engaging States so they get input and
try to get some buy-in from some at
least some key states so that would be
the next thing we would see that may
take three or four months sometime in
may be the third quarter of 2013 EPA
would propose a standard that standard
then legally is required to be available
for public comment that that's typically
a 90-day period where anybody can say
anything they want about it typically
that will be you know mostly utilities
and some environmental groups providing
technical comments about how it could be
strengthened or weakened or why it's bad
idea last time when EPA proposed a they
did propose they did they do have a
proposal standard for new power plants
which was issued last year and the
environmental community actually
mobilized public support to demonstrate
that there's a real desire to have EPA
move forward and over three million
public comments were submitted in favor
of EPA finalizing that standard which is
far more than EPA has ever received on
any previous rulemaking so we would we
would
probably engage in that type of
mobilization again in addition to
providing public comments more technical
comments so that process takes about a
year between proposal and final rule so
we'd expect a final rule to be issued in
towards the end of 2014 probably after
the midterm election and then and then
States would be given probably about a
year to submit implementation plans so
we don't actually you know the first
date in which companies would be legally
required to meet this kind of standard
is probably not till 2018 maybe not even
till 2020 but once the process starts I
think one of the important things to
keep in mind is it will actually have an
impact right away in fact the
possibility of this happening is already
I think having an impact on investment
decisions over the next three years
power plant owners have to decide you
own it a coal plant it doesn't already
have the full set of emission controls
on it it will by 2015 2016 need to be
retrofit to comply with the mercury
standards that's a big investment to
make knowing that EPA has the ability to
set this as well we think will actually
start to influence those decisions and
more more people will say you know
that's probably not a good investment to
try to keep this coal plant running for
the next 30 years because we need to
move to clean your options can you add
Mike
so what's the cost though if they were
to choose let's say to go with to
convert to a sort of methane plant you
know is that's the other would be the
other option of an existing coal plant
right when they be able to easily move
into that that resource yeah so it
depends on a lot of things our analysis
actually showed that the maiden and
cheapest compliance option would be to
have energy efficiency programs that
that reduce demand and that that
reduction in demand would essentially
reduce the need for generation from the
coal plants natural gas would be some
growth in generation from natural gas
but kind of it the business as usual
rate so it ends up shifting the mix
towards more gas but mostly by having
energy efficiency and renewables replace
coal you know it all depends on and I
should say that those types of programs
are designed to kind of overcome these
behavioral barriers that you know the
one the programs that are effective are
ones that actually keep people say
rebate so that they buy more efficient
equipment rather than say just you know
send you a note that says please turn
down your thermostat those those don't
work for the reasons that we just heard
but programs and where you you know by a
seer 15 air conditioner instead of a
seer 12 and you'll get 100 rebate those
those programs actually work so so those
kinds of things but it just like the
coal versus gas if you're looking at two
plants that are both exist so one
question is you know you have to need
build a new plant or not right now
there's actually quite a bit of spare
capacity and in particular a lot of
natural gas plants that are not operated
at full capacity with gas prices where
they've been over the last year that's
pretty much a wash and it's about 3
cents a kilowatt hour to generate with
either coal or gas gas prices go up you
know they'll be
some margin there if you have to build a
new plant at the totally different story
I had a question for cliff I thought it
was interesting that people have such
unrealistic ideas about how easy it
would be to make changes but I wondered
if you ask them instead about their
willingness instead of how easy they
thought it would be would you've gotten
different responses thank you for that
question Trudy that this is really a
current debate I guess among the social
behavioral scientists on how you survey
people there is one type of survey that
willingness to pay survey that does
target exactly people's willingness to
pay a particular amount and the the
results of those surveys suggest that a
person's will how a person answers a
survey like that is somewhat different
than how much they actually shell out
when it comes time to pull out their
wallet and so I'm not real optimistic
that if you ask the question that way
that there would be that it would
reflect more of the truth which is of
course what we're what we're really
after here the the results conceivably
could be somewhat somewhat different but
whether it really reflects what people
what people's actions would be is
another another question entirely cliff
isn't one of the reasons for that that
people are very aware of how they might
perceive be perceived when they're
taking the survey and so they want to be
seen as somebody who thinks that it's
easier who is very willing yet yes
actually Peter that that's right and for
that purpose all of these surveys are
are done you know with
anonymous coding and what we're trying
to do of course is to dispel any concern
that people might have that they would
be identified with their response I
wonder just jumping off of that if
you've taken a look at a revealed
preference framework so in economics
there's been this debate about
willingness to pay for a variety of
different you know environmental
amenities and services for a long time
and and where a lot of people come down
is really what we need to do is try and
figure out ways instead of serving
people of actually measuring their
behavior you know what they do do and
then potentially compare that that with
what they say they're going to do to
understand what sort of likely is that
something that you guys feel like you
can look at or thinking about um We
certainly have thought a lot about it
and a lot of times this entails doing
things like like getting access to
persons energy bills and looking looking
at their their energy consumption month
to month and so forth so yes we're we're
looking into those kinds of studies
conducting that those kinds of studies
is really a totally different regime
than conducting the surveys but in fact
I agree with you that's the kind of
information that that we really would
like to have I think there is a question
every day
this is going back to trudys
presentation I'm wondering what you see
as the next steps in reducing the
uncertainties related to aerosols are
there specific on the ground or I mean
remote sensing measurements we need or
as most of this going to happen in the
modeling world do you think um thanks
for the question yeah i think you know
as the study that just came out on black
carbon showed remote sensing and
monitoring is really important to
actually keep track of what emissions
are in different parts of the world and
that's you know what we're feeding into
our models so that's that's crucial
clearly so that's first Apple is to know
what emissions are and how they're
changing and especially some regions
where they're changing rapidly but then
there's also the issue of you know in
modeling that we don't really understand
a lot of mechanisms in the atmosphere
very well when it comes to for example
by carbon and how it affects clouds and
that's that is potentially a major
contributor to the net forcing so I
think we have to work hard on many
fronts and I wish that we had time to
really nail down all these things
especially from the modeling side before
we acted but clearly that's not an
option we have to live with those
uncertainties and make decisions even
with them so yeah we have to to work on
many friends at the same time and also
accept making decisions under
uncertainty so on that point dan I
wonder is someone who works on climate
and clean air policy how do you view the
potential conflict between carbon
policies and policies that might produce
these other pollutants yeah you know
it's an interesting question I actually
don't see it as a conflict in practice I
just think we you know I look at it
pretty simply I think less pollution is
better and if you want less carbon
pollution you have to regulate carbon
pollution
you don't let sorry using language that
we use for public engagement purposes so
people don't understand what greenhouse
gases are so we talk about carbon
pollution now it's interesting because
we spent years distinguishing greenhouse
gases from other type of pollutants and
we conclude that was completely nuts
from a public perception point of view
it's like you know people generally
think less pollution is better than more
pollution so let's just work with that
anyway so if you want less co2 you
regulate co2 if you want less sulfate
because fine particles kill people
regulate sulfate there are some coke
benefits and co interactions but
ultimately you know we really just need
to push as hard as we can on all these
fronts and so I think it's it's it's
been interesting to watch the attention
to black carbon and my reaction to it
had been at least in the US where we've
been regulating part particulates diesel
particulate very strictly quite frank
and and and we've started to crack down
on on sulfur emissions from power plants
it's like well viewing it as a climate
force it does it cause you to do
anything different than what you're
already doing in the air pollution
regime and I think the answer is no now
that's it's probably a different answer
if you think about biomass burning or
some other other sources but yeah and
interest in your reaction yeah i think
if you think about air quality in
isolation and and you don't keep in mind
what the climate effects could be you
could get some very unpleasant surprises
actually so you have to be very well
aware for example with sulfur that if
you you're reducing it for air quality
purposes that you may accelerate warming
as as a consequence and and actually I
was very inspired by marc jacobs's talk
yesterday but I thought about it
afterwards and I think you know if we
could in fact transition to all this
renewable energy the immediate effect on
climate would actually be a warming
because you are removing these
short-lived aerosol species from the
atmosphere the long term is clear it's a
benefit to climate as well
but we may actually see a very
accelerated warming if we were at all
possible to or able to transition to the
these renewable fuels so that's we have
to at least brace for that or be
prepared for that if if we were to the
decision so yeah I mean I agree that we
need to be aware of it but and I think
well what is the implication of that
well if you have an opportunity to have
a pollution standard that's going to
save 10,000 lives a year because we're
reducing particle pollution am I going
to say don't do that because it might
accelerate warming the short-term now
I'm going to say well we got to do that
and we got to also simultaneously do
everything we can to reduce carbon
polluter emissions and methane emissions
so that we're trying to address the
longer term forcing at the same time I
in practice I still don't quite know
what I do differently being aware that
there may be this sort of unmasking
effect so I just wanted to mention that
of course in Europe more than half of
their personal automobiles are operated
with diesel but they have they have
succeeded in using new diesel technology
which is which is fairly clean and so
you know one could argue that that in
Europe they have some benefits of
reduced air quality or pollution but
also a higher energy efficiency that you
can that you can get with diesel I'm
just wondering if that's something that
that you've considered down well it's
interesting I mean the US market doesn't
seem to be going towards diesel the
efficiency standards that i mentioned
will continue to boost the the fuel
economy of the fleet but so far and in
diesel would be an option that
automakers have but it's actually pretty
relatively expensive diesel engines are
more expensive to build and gasoline
engine so we're mostly seeing other
types of technological improvements
hybridization in various forms sort of
mild hybrids where you just have a
little bit of battery and you you shut
the engine off automatically when you
come to a stop gives you a little bit of
boost allows you to downsize that the
engine block a little bit without
sacrificing perception of you know pick
up in power is one thing that that's
certainly happening vehicles are
becoming lighter is people start using
more aluminum and carbon fiber materials
I think in the long run you know you do
get it mate it probably fifteen percent
something like fifteen to twenty percent
benefit from a diesel engine versus a
gasoline engine that's not going to get
us what we need to be so you do need to
move to either electric vehicles or
sustainable bio fuel vehicles in order
to so and I think I think that's more
the direction the US markets tending
towards now so I I doubt we'll see a big
upsurge in diesel in the u.s. part of
the part of the push in Europe it has
been a result of some what I mean of a
very different tax treatment so in
Europe the trucker's you know it's it's
not like their politics are free of
lobbying either the trucker's were
successful in keeping the tax rate on
diesel fuel much lower than the tax rate
on gasoline they're still both much
higher than their in the US but but that
made it very attractive for consumers
than to have diesel vehicles and we
don't have that differential tax
treatment here so other questions follow
up so I have to agree with you then that
of course from an air quality
perspective you want to reduce aerosol
constant concentrations across the board
perhaps independent of of climate but I
also want to remind you that Marc Jacobs
and brought up arctic sea ice yesterday
and that you know we may see it
disappear over than
10 to 20 years and really the short term
climate forcers could really make a
difference in this context and you know
it's also a question of weighing lives
lost due to air quality and life's loss
to to climate change although it's
harder to measure lives lost as a
response to climate change but it may
not be as clear cut once you factor in
all though all these things and also i
want to remind everyone that people are
thinking about geoengineering we're
actually you purposely put more sulfur
in the atmosphere to counter global
warming so so while we're we're sitting
here saying that it's a no-brainer that
we should reduce also sulfur independent
of its climate affect other people are
thinking about putting more sulfur in
the atmosphere to combat global warming
so just yeah to remind everyone of that
no it's um it's probably been a little
too glib about it I you know if I think
it does make sense to try to concentrate
it particularly if there are sources
where the black carbon dominates over
the other aerosols to see what you can
do to put a particular focus on those
that that certainly helps in the short
run focusing on reducing methane which
is sort of intermediate usually called a
short term climate for sir but really is
an intermediate term kind of course
there's something where we could get a
relatively quick response so we
definitely should be doing that as well
you know putting sulfur ania in this
Stratus so so people are talking about
putting solver they're not saying put it
into the air that people breathe right
they are saying put it in the
stratosphere generally but yeah but but
there may you know that all kinds of
complications with that such as what
what effect it has on the ozone layer
and things of that nature I guess the
one area where you maybe I would say we
ought to think twice about my general
mantra that less pollution is better is
in
in shipping so international shipping
they tend to use the worst the highest
sulfur bunker fuels and there is a
movement as those ships come into port
to require them to switch over to
cleaner fuels to reduce the health
effects in in port cities but maybe
that's an area where you say well if
you're out in the open ocean burn that
high sulfur fuel let that sulfur go in
the atmosphere Mabel you get a little
bit of a climate benefit from now I
think we have time for one more question
if anyone has one yes so the first yci
students imposing we had was actually
about black carbon and it seemed like
then there was a lot of discussion in
the policy sphere and in the media about
regulating black carbon for the short
term climate benefits but it seems like
four or five years later there's not
that much of the policy discussion
around reduction of black carbon so this
question is for Trudy and Dan I mean for
Trudy is it really necessary or should
we still be thinking about black carbon
reductions from a policy perspective and
Dan is there any of that type of
discussion happening in Washington or as
that phase already passed and we're now
looking down the line at something else
yeah so in terms of them for black
carbon you you saw that there is a very
active research going on and you know
kneeling down what the actual climate
force forcing is from black carbon and I
think just from judging from the
attention that the study got that just
came out I think people are still
thinking about black carbon and I again
I think it's a no-brainer to try to
reduce black carbon from an air quality
perspective and as long as we could at
least show that it's not going to harm
climate I think that would help policy
like I said unfortunately we have to
live with these large uncertainty ranges
and I don't see that we're going to
reduce them within you know the next
decade or so and we probably have to
make some decisions before
before that so there's active research
and I think you know there's research to
inform policy but but there are certain
uncertainties that we can't get rid of a
lot of scientific uncertainty in the
u.s. right they don't want to hear about
it no they don't want to know but there
is actually active policy discussion I
mean one the international negotiations
on climate are pretty bogged down but
one of the initiatives last year was a
initiative on short term climate forcers
at Secretary Clinton kind of elevated
it's not a huge amount of money behind
it but it is sort of put a little bit of
a spotlight on that those I think more
generally there is quite a bit of
discussion about then you know let's not
just talk about carbon dioxide we have
to deal with methane hfcs some of which
are relatively short-lived hi hi GG WP
gases and and black carbon a lot of a
lot of the black carbonation is you know
I think the challenge is what what do
you actually do then and is it effective
so you know improved cookstoves is one
area where you might do something and
you know but what will that do to is it
again what's the ratio of black carbon
organic carbon is you reduce those
emissions behavioral change talk about a
real challenge people have cooked
traditionally in one way for you know
generations and generations not not not
at all easy I think there's a lot of
kind of loose thinking that that would
be just simple you just give people good
cook stoves if something gets cried
every once in a while and people abandon
it because we didn't do anything then 10
years later they come back say let's do
a cook stove initiative so we have to
think pretty carefully about that the
one area that we're active in which I do
think is promising again I'm not sure
exactly what the net climate benefits
will be but the public health benefits
will be really big is to try to get
basically a global phase-out not quite
out but a global phase down of sulfur in
diesel fuel so we did this a few years
ago with lead now
basically there's no lead and he's in
gasoline anywhere in the world except
maybe North Korea and some other rope
country but it's pretty much gone and of
course that enables a bunch of other
pollution control technologies same
thing with low sulfur diesel enables
particulate controls on diesel engines
and you know if all you do is just take
the sulfur out then you're clearly going
to have a warming effect from that
although they'll be health benefits but
if you then use that to enable much
tighter particulate controls on diesel
emissions which something the US has
done Europe is done but is not
widespread throughout the rest of the
world then I guess hopefully it's about
a wash on climate and you've got very
substantial public benefits all right
well thank you so much cliff Trudy and
Dan excellent panel and thank you for
sharing your research with this yeah
thank you everybody and with that we'll
wrap up our panel events for the day
given the snow will have will have some
beef closing remarks from our director
of the yellow climate and energy
institute professor mark Pagani and then
we'll move forward to lunch yes it's
snowing in fact i think you know our
climate models have lots of uncertainty
but a really good predictor of extreme
weather is why CI symposiums because
this is the second one that was screwed
up by first one was hurricane sandy you
know we had to postpone that until
january and now we're on our second one
with the next blizzard so i think it's a
good predictor you want to put on your
calendars next time you see something
we're doing you may want to stay home uh
so okay first so i want to thank all our
speakers and guess that they were very
injured you know just great talks and i
also want to thank the student
organizers danina hot spots key Natalie
Schultz Candice
harbour angel sue and Peter Kristin to
you know who worked tirelessly to build
this this is the fourth event and and I
am always impressed by by by the outcome
at least the outcome in the in terms of
intellectual content and and I'll and
I'll just say one a couple of words just
for my own perspective because you know
why not you know I have one more there's
always another perspective on climate
when you're thinking about climates and
you're thinking about all these things
obviously there's a you know a brilliant
array of problems and and questions
right and depending on your focus that's
where you tend to sit and think about
that particular focus during these you
know this debate in this last few
comments this idea of human health and
pollution and for me just let you know
from my perspective it's only about heat
and I have zero concern almost about
anything else anymore you know it's a
simplest way for me to reduce the
problem heat is the climate system and
that's affects everything else in you
know every everything else is going to
follow from heat and heat distribution
and that's greenhouse gases and no
matter what we do with greenhouse gases
whether they're short term effects or
long term effects like co2 which by the
way has a residence time of thousands of
10,000 really actually hundreds of
thousands of years you know this is not
a simple problem the heat you know the
cheat generated by these gases
eventually all it all goes into the
ocean and when you extract the
greenhouse gases if you were to spend
the money and you had the commitment and
the backbone that heat then is pumped
out of the ocean and the few studies
that have looked at this sort of
relationship between heat generated and
it and then sequestered into the ocean
and then released is that there's a
balance meaning that there's even if you
were to wait if you were to wait 50 or
60 or 70 years before you accomplish the
solution where you reduced the co2 you
would then have a heat source from the
ocean that would be equivalent to the
greenhouse forcing for hundreds of years
so that there's actually you know
there's e to the problem because the you
know heat is is
put it into the ocean and will be
released so that once you have that you
know problem then it's all about
geoengineering in fact it's all about
geoengineering in many ways before you
can get started on the solution which is
one of these fantastical problems where
this is what the last few conversations
were about sulphate and increasing the
albedo of the earth in order to keep the
heat away from the surface of the earth
that's a it's even though it sounds like
science fiction it's a it's part of the
solution and so I just want to leave you
with that thought that there is actually
urgency here and and I'm learning every
time we have one of these meetings and I
and Jesse and yesterday with Jacob tins
talk my hope my whole perspective on
renewable fuels it was altered so anyway
I just want to leave it with that and
thank our guests their sushi from me as
upstairs for those who have come we will
reward you with with food and drink
upstairs so please join us for lunch
thanks
you